was getting a thousand impressions a day. Now I'm getting five to 10. He's the one. Do you remember
which one this was the guy who had to add suspension? What would you recommend in that?
Things are going good, getting good impressions, gets a suspension unsuspends and now he's only
getting five to 10 a day. Is that something where he needs to just go recreate it because
he's kind of got a black black X on him or is it just time of year and some other factors?
Probably other factors. Go check population, budget, CPC, go look at the edit, make sure there
hasn't been increases. That's probably more it than that. Typically once you're done with the
suspension you're fine. They don't really hover over it unless you're being a jerk and you continue
to push the buttons then they'll flag you but none of us here are trying to do that so once
you're through it you're good.